it was a Sunday afternoon back in April
of this year my phone was ringing I
picked it up the voice said it's Rebecca
I'm just calling to invite you to my
funeral
I said Rebecca what are you talking
about
she said joy asked my friend you have to
let me go it's my time the next day she
was dead
Rebecca was 31 years old
when she died she had an eight-year
struggle with breast cancer it came back
three times I failed her the scientific
community failed her and the medical
community failed her and she's not the
only one every five seconds someone dies
of cancer
today we medical researchers are
committed to having Rebecca and people
like her be one of the last patients
that we fail the US government alone has
spent over a hundred billion on cancer
research since the 1970s with limited
progress in regards to patient survival
especially for certain types of very
aggressive cancers so we need a change
because clearly what we've been doing so
far has not been working and what we do
in medicine is to send out firefighters
because cancer is like a big fire and
these firefighters are the cancer drugs
but we're sending them out without a
firetruck so without transportation
without ladders and without emergency
equipment and over 99% of these
firefighters
make it to the fire over 99% of cancer
drugs never make it to the tumor because
they lack transportation and tools to
take them to the location they're aiming
for turns out it really is all about
location location location so we need a
fire truck to get to the right location
and I'm here to tell you that
nanoparticles are the fire trucks we can
load cancer drugs inside nanoparticles
and nanoparticles can function as the
carrier and necessary equipment to bring
the cancer drugs to the heart of the
tumor so what are nanoparticles and what
does it really mean to be nano sized
well there are many different types of
nanoparticles made out of various
materials such as metal based
nanoparticles or facts based
nanoparticles but to really illustrate
what it means to be nano sized I took
one of my hair strands and placed it
under the microscope now I have very
thin hair so my hair is approximately
40,000 nanometers in diameter so this
means if we take 400 over nano particles
and we stack them on top of each other
we get the thickness of a single hair
strand so I lead a nanoparticle
laboratory to fight cancer and other
diseases at Mayo Clinic here in
Jacksonville and a Mayo Clinic we really
have the tools to make a difference for
patients thanks to the generous
donations and grants to fund our
research and so how do these
nanoparticles manage to transport cancer
drugs to the tumor well they have an
extensive toolbox
so cancer drugs without nanoparticles
are quickly washed out of the body
through the kidneys because they're so
small so it's like water going through a
sieve and so they don't really have time
to reach the tomb
and here we see an illustration of this
we have the firefighters the cancer
drugs they're circulating in the blood
but they're quickly washed out of the
body and they don't really end up inside
the tumor but if we put these cancer
drugs inside nanoparticles they will not
get washed out by the body because the
nanoparticles are too big and they will
continue to circulate in the blood
giving them more time to find the tumor
and here we see that the cancer drugs
the firefighters inside the fire truck
the nanoparticles they're circulating in
the blood they don't get washed out and
they actually end up reaching the tumor
and so what other tools do nanoparticles
have well they can protect cancer drugs
from getting destroyed inside the body
there are certain very important but
sensitive drugs that are easily degraded
by enzymes in the blood so unless they
have this nanoparticle protection they
will not be able to function
another nanoparticle tool are the
surface extensions that are like tiny
hands with fingers that grab on to the
tumor and fit exactly onto it so that
when the nanoparticles are circulating
they can attach onto the cancer cells
buying the cancer drugs more time to do
their job and these are just some of the
many tools that nanoparticles can have
and today we have more than 10
clinically approved nanoparticles for
cancer that are given to patients all
over the world yet we have patients like
Rebecca who died so what are the major
challenges and limitations with
currently approved nanoparticles well a
major challenge is the liver because the
liver is the body's filtration system
and the liver recognizes and destroys
foreign objects such as viruses bacteria
and also nanoparticles and the immune
cells in the liver eat the nanoparticles
preventing them
from reaching the tumor and here we see
an illustration where the kidney is no
longer a problem but these fire trucks
the nanoparticles get stuck in the liver
and actually actually less of them end
up reaching the tumor so a future
strategy to improve nanoparticles is to
temporarily disarm the immune cells in
the liver so how do we disarm these
cells well we looked at drugs that were
already clinically approved for other
indications to see if any of them could
stop the immune cells from eating the
nanoparticles and unexpectedly in one of
our preclinical studies we found that a
70 year-old malaria drug was able to
stop the immune cells from internalizing
the nanoparticles so that they could
escape the liver and continue that
journey to their goal the tumor and here
we see the illustration of blocking
deliver the nanoparticles don't go there
and they instead end up in the tumor so
sometimes unexpected connections are
made in science that lead to new
solutions another strategy for
preventing nanoparticles from getting
stuck in the liver is to use the body's
own nanoparticles yes surprise surprise
you and you and you and all of us have a
lot of nanoparticles circulating in our
bodies and because they're part of our
bodies the liver is less likely to label
them as foreign and these biological
nanoparticles can be found in the saliva
in the blood in the urine in pancreatic
juice and we can collect them from the
body and use them as fire trucks for
cancer drugs and in this case the immune
cells in the liver are less likely to
eat the biological nanoparticles so
we're using a Trojan horse based concept
to fool the liver and here we see the
biological Nano car
circulating in the blood they don't get
recognized by the liver and they end up
in the tumor and in the future we want
to exploit nature's own nanoparticles
for cancer drug delivery to reduce side
effects and save lives by preventing the
cancer drugs from being in the wrong
location however a major problem has
been how do we isolate these biological
nanoparticles in large quantities
without damaging them my lab has
developed an efficient method for doing
this we can process large quantities of
liquids from the body to produce a
highly concentrated high-quality
formulation or biological nanoparticles
and these nanoparticles are not yet
in clinical use because it takes an
average of 12 years to get something
from the lab to your medicine cabinet
and this is the type of challenge that
requires teamwork from scientists and
physicians who dedicate their lives to
this battle and we keep going
thanks to inspiration from patients and
I believe that if we keep working on
these nano medicines we will be able to
reduce harm to health the organs improve
quality of life and save future patients
I like to imagine that if these
treatments had been available for
Rebecca that call from her could have
been an invitation not to her funeral
but her wedding thank you
[Applause]
[Music]